all right for people joining the
livestream welcome to a language
completeness and consistency meeting
about what language and we have a
variety of topics let us start with a
random one hahaha
about random state okay so random state
Wow
so remind me so random state is
basically something that contains all if
possible contains all the seeding
information that you can then feed the
two-seed random to completely restore
your reproduce you know your results if
you want to and if you look at the
example below with OpenSSL then you know
it says reproducibility not guaranteed
in fact for OpenSSL we could say well
you won't have reproducibility but I'm
not sure what's up with that broken
message I'll have to test it in an
updated build and see if it's a was a
build issue okay let me make a
suggestion just like in cryptography
where we have um um that's fine John by
the way um the somebody's got a bunch of
weird background noise here but but um
okay
just like in cryptography where we have
that kind of bitmap pattern that
indicates what the underlying data is
that might be useful here as well that
is if you've got three random States you
don't know what they are
either that or a hash of the random
state or something something that shows
you what which one is which
understand what I'm saying yeah right so
the the state may consist of more than
one you know I'm aware yeah I'm aware
yeah the hash of everything that's
involved I mean the
we could either call it state hash and
then just give it you know give a short
hash that's about that long we don't
need a giant hash mm-hmm right I would
just call it next what method state hash
and then now in this case here with
reproducibility not guaranteed what why
does that does it even have a state hash
no there's nothing there so I mean
they're in the same kernel session well
so open SSL is like great there's
completely random right that's totally
outside of our control for something
like mkl there's some nonzero chance if
you're in the same kernel session that
it finds via the pointer to write state
but it's also basically there's no real
state data in there so we could say well
that's not correct there there is there
is so so for example with an in jail in
the random state expression yes but but
associated with that is a is a is an
address of the expression which which
has a pointer into the mko and mkl
supports copying the expression but we
don't have a serialization for it
why not why not just two by two right
because because the mkl would not be
able to recognize that memory again if
we're open again now mkl now does
support that but that's a completely
different project so that we still not
ready yet but eventually we'll be able
to do it could be read so I reckon what
we should do its method expensi a fine
then we should have another great thing
state hash colon and then some random
pieces of hex or something yes when that
could be that could be D that could be
the hash of the expression address in
cases where we don't actually have a
state
which will it's trying to do is tell you
if it's the same thing um by the way I
mean this idea of using a state hash and
so on there probably other blobs like
for open streams or God knows what else
we're having that kind of hash will be
useful we do effectively have a hash for
open streams don't we we have a pointer
location is that correct somebody know
it I you know don't you
[Music]
right I mean you know the stream
position no no no it's something
different if I say streams mm-hmm oh
it's now just got a thing called unique
ID Wow okay all right well it's just one
two it used to be
hex something rather if I say links
don't I see something like that oh yeah
there we go look at that name ad yg blah
blah blah well I mean right that's the
name that you could use the link connect
to it right where did that name come
from it's essentially a hash isn't it or
a UUID well that's well maybe John can
answer that question but that's the name
that math link report W SDP reports to
the kernel soon Akane's like yeah I
heard my name mentioned question is in
these link objects whether these weird
IDs what are they where do they come
from so in the in the case of loop
backlinks I'm not 100% certain although
I can makes a pretty educated guess in
the case of the shared memory links it
is basically a randomized you know text
generation thing it's just and that's
also checking to make sure hasn't been
used before
right and the underscore s hm is that
remember that
that yes yeah yeah that's that's always
a pendant for a shared memory protocol
you and you know the name of course you
know depends on the protocol because you
know like on TCP it's going to be port
at IP address comma port at IP address
okay I mean this probably we don't need
to fix this right now but one day it'd
be nice to sort of you you idea fie
these things since we now this pattern
of you you IDs yeah you know that would
be possible
yeah the I mean there are some questions
that that raises like if I close a link
and then open one on the same named
channel is that the same you idea is
that a new UUID I and it's it's not
totally obvious to me actually which
would be the case but yeah yeah that's
not unreasonable though okay
make a note but that's our critical
thing for right now okay so here okay
you can go back to not paying attention
John great thanks
yeah um by the way aren't we
standardizing on lower cases for this
for these some for these things and
blobs I'm confused by that somebody
tried to make that okay well fine but
can we just check consistency of that
because I I ran into something recently
that seemed to be different from that
who's being here sorry that the okay
could you try and track that down maybe
with other PM's yes um okay so method
state hash
um and then here this would be
well if we have state hash you know a
hash instead state hash not available
I'm not sure we still need that that
line yes I agree because state hash
presumably tells you that there isn't a
I mean I don't even know what
reproducibility not guaranteed means
because in a sense by saying there is a
random state well what is in there if it
isn't something that you can reuse yes
well well what's in there is basically
the method name the exact method
specification so you can return to that
same method method but not necessarily
the same right right so within within
the same kernel session it will return
to the in many cases it will reach and
with open SSL it will not but with other
generators that will return to this so
should there be a state hash or not a
state hash in that case do you
understand the question I mean is that
should there be I think it's useful to
have a state hash whenever yeah is there
only one open SSL generator yeah
whenever there should be a state hash
whenever you need to distinguish two
different threads of random number
generation within a single session see
what I'm saying yeah yeah okay so then I
think that the only thing we need to
annotate here
is when when you have I mean really what
this is Khilafah is when there's state
data in the random state object and when
there isn't I understand but I'm saying
if there's no state hash not available
that's okay that's that's understandable
the case is there's a state hash
available but it is not session not
intercession reproducible correct right
right well but I mean maybe Rob is
proposing to somehow add that but at the
present time there's no way to access
the only way to access that state hash
is to save the variable save the result
in the variable and then the reference
that variable because it's this is keyed
off of pointer equality right and if you
copy that output into an input cell it
will not be an expression with the same
pointer value so it's a very very weak
form of okay so look
something like this that useful to say
that in the case where there is a state
hash but another case that state hash
not available does that make sense
basically what would what would have to
be done is is in cases where we don't
have a state that the hash would be
would be the expression address fine and
for those states we know that method so
then we go back to the address and say
okay you want to restore that state
you'll go back to that address for that
I mean it takes a little work to
implement that but I think it's doable
okay all right fine okay
so then for the method are we are we
camel izing it like this or are we I
mean are we breaking it apart i we could
catalyze it probably right so the right
this corresponds more or less to the
option values of method which are
documented which are arab camel strings
okay that's fine yeah I think I think it
should match the string that you set the
method to okay that's fine
fine fine fine fine fine okay next
question the name random state I'm a
little concerned about it's too generic
a name and that we should we should have
something like random generator state or
something that'd be fine well are you
happy with that
[Music]
and that seems reasonable I mean not
that this is really a strong point
either way but write it we called it
random generator state and we could have
$8.00 random generator state and then
the obsolete dollar random state can
stay as is for whoever still uses this
symbol that's been obsolete for twelve
or fourteen years yeah leave it leave
that symbol leave Colorado State right
it won't look like that I know Colonel
it it gives you some carbon in terms of
integers in random legacy yeah okay
great all right so then in order to how
do you localize it cuz use block random
to localize nowadays right yes okay
questions on our live stream need a
property on the state hash let us know
what type it is so in other words you're
suggesting that random generators state
take a sub value to be able to query its
method they think they're more concerned
about since they mentioned what kind of
hash it is I think they're more
concerned about how do you distinguish a
hash of real data versus a hash of a
pointer not sure exactly how useful that
is but they don't have them well I think
that it's useful to be able to get
method there and to get hashed there
mm-hmm
why not I mean harmless different
functions that do that Stephen I mean
maybe maybe that's you know if you want
to
what do you say I'm just suggesting
though if you want to get the current
method okay though the thing you do is
just do seed in fact we should probably
have an argument to seed seed random no
it's not a sense of way to do it I mean
a good way to do that is to just say
dollar random generator state and then
take the result and say sub method take
the result that you've got here where
you can see visually what the method is
but you might want that programmatically
and you can extract that by some kind of
method sub value on the random generator
stage yeah I was saying about doing that
anyway for fine I'll do it
okay what about states and remote sub
kernels versus the state in the front
end well I think that wherever this is
running is where it the state in the
front end the front end doesn't we only
know the front end State this is not
addressing the front end state this is
addressing the kernel State so lock
random I just again we're looking at the
name here lock random what is the
analogue I mean it's something as weird
as dollar module number this thing um I
think dollar annum generator state is
less obscure because among other things
it's all the randoms flow into this I
don't know what are we saying the
documentation for block random
sit around and generators localized yeah
so I think random generator stasis
alright alright everything done on this
one yep done I'm happily we were
avoiding the backward and compatibility
to so that's really good okay onward
this looks horrifying this next one yeah
and I think it's good that we have
prepared this week see what's also
involved in this right so we have this
list of exclusions which maybe maybe
maybe the problem is that this is over
broad and we need to sort of reduce it
to sort of its core things which are you
know list representations patterns and
you know I'm not sure how critical
interpolating function and various
things like that maybe Rob has opinions
okay let's be clear what's going on here
the issue is that users are thinking of
some head in their world as being
spurious symbolic and not in need of an
activation no that is not the problem
okay
the problem is the users are reading the
ref page and believe that inactivate in
activates every any head they give it
but certain heads aren't inactivated and
that surprises oh really yes which heads
are they surprised about I list
surprises some people although I think
that's crazy if I might say so but it
you know if that's because they're not
really thinking about the implications
of what would happen if list weren't
activated but sort of graphics was the
most recent report what what did they
think was going to happen and what did
happen I'm very confused to me so if I
take if I do this if I say graphics of
disk and then I say inactivate that well
you can't do that they want the input
form basically right so nothing happens
but if you do inactive of graphics of
disk then you get a sort of human
readable representation of graphics okay
great
what's the point here the point is the
people wants it to not work people did
they want the zero to be inactivated as
well no but they wanted the graphics to
be inactivated in nf6 do they want the
disk to be inactivated or is it in fact
inactivated if I look at the input form
there no it's not okay how come because
graphics is treated as a as what what's
called an expression exclusion so once
you hit it you skip the entirety you
don't even burrow into it as you know
which you do burrow into Tom and I used
to use the analogy of boats taking on
water for these kinds of situations
where the thing the thing is basically
sinking in a pile of heuristics and it's
like you know you're pumping water out
at a certain rate and the thing is
sinking at a certain rate I mean I mean
I think inactivate is a heuristic
function and that's the way it is and
that's what makes it useful I think if
you try to make the documentation makes
no no gives no indication okay with that
wrong that's wrong the documentation
should document that it attempts to it
should make some vague statement about
how it attempts to do useful
inactivation and that if you really want
to inactivated what would you do you
would map how would you do it you'd do
some kind of math no no no no no no no
no no I mean a user level way of doing
it not some it's a documented symbol it
has opposed you could but I think I
think it'd be better to give people if
you really want to like decorate an
expression completely with an activate
inactive let me make a general comment
here so we have been planning for the
last three or four years to work in more
detail on on a sort of operating on held
expressions and I think we understand
quite a lot more about how to do that
and I don't think we should lock down
every aspect of how inactivate works
before we've done that because I think
there may be some small changes that we
need so I think we should just make the
statement of the documentation that it
heuristic Lee tries to inactivate useful
things we can comment on this if we want
to we can we can at least indicate there
is such a list and leave it at that
I just don't think but it will be good
to be able to give people something I
mean unfortunately there isn't a map
head that just goes and decorates all
the heads in expression if there was you
could do a replace at level you know
zero to minus one where you do head you
know H blank of stuff goes to in that
but that's very I mean if we had a map
head that could go to level infinity
then we probably could do this of
wrapping every head and inactive I mean
it's an operation that is not usually
useful the other possibility is that an
activate could take some arguments here
that determines what it does
right and and the exclusion list
overrides the pattern so that's another
thing that people confuse so they
explicitly say an activate list and yet
it doesn't an activate list but that's
the only sensible thing cuz if you break
the pattern is just blank right I agree
that the default behavior I agree I'm
just saying yeah this isn't an adequate
piece of documentation right it
obviously has to say that it's excluding
certain things okay the question is if
you want to inactivate everything how do
you do it so you know on the inactivate
exclusions ref page there are examples
of that so you just block that to empty
list or set it to empty list if you
right if you want it to do that and if
you don't want to use an activator I
think that question why isn't an
activate Expo comma list why doesn't it
just inactivate list why does it want to
go and and you know have a sort of a an
extra exclusions thing after that right
well what if it's list or underscore
question mark numeric you write your dad
applied the exclusions or not for if
pattern is numbers basically look it
seems to me that this function
personally what I would think about
doing is something like this that it has
three arguments all together the exper
the things you want to inactivate and a
list of exclusions and if you want to
the default list of exclusions can be
the one you've given here I don't know
the priority order of the second and
third arguments but if you want to just
inactivate everything you would say
inactivate exper and then blank comma
and then there no exclusions so you get
some no list or something there right
yeah that's uh that's uh that's possible
I don't think that would even be very
hard to do I think I think writing that
the documentation for that would
probably be harder than the
implementation I think it's rather easy
to write documentation it says that the
third argument defaults to automatic and
it uses a automatic built-in list of
exclusions which could be changed by
using developer and activate exclusions
right well the question is should that
just be a flat list of symbols or should
it support the more general syntax of
dollar and activate exclusions which has
two types of exclusions what would all
those two types how do I see that here
so just remove the first slash at and so
that's I believe the string symbol and
the string expression in the second
argument saying so symbol means ignore
the symbol but burrow in an expression
means once you see this heads full stop
and go elsewhere okay I absolutely think
it should support this I think it should
allow an association or something that
gives lists of symbols and a list of
expression heads right correct names for
them and I think that gives the
possibility of other kinds of exclusions
later I also think some of the things
that are excluded here are bonkers yeah
I I agree this was I mean this was sort
of the last thing we did before we ship
then and we never circled back to it so
I agree this guy definitely could use a
fresh look right okay um okay so let's
review the the syntax here that we're
talking about okay so you know in modern
usage we would
you know the common thing would be an
expert coma all but not unfortunately
will inactivate all which is very weird
and obscure so I think this is
inactivate everything yep and then this
is the list of exclusions which should
be applied obviously before the
inactivation list because well is it
before or after well we're saying so
that means that yes it's before because
this would be a match this would match
all hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on so this would be that's pattern what
about a list they're all symbols in Expo
so that could perfectly well be a list
of symbols there which I think is a good
thing to have okay and I think it should
probably support string named symbols as
you get from names as well and possibly
even reg X's that involve contexts the
only question is could it support all
I mean all would be a weird thing you'd
want to inactivate but it just seems
like yeah well I mean but also always
used as a terminal isn't it it's never
unless you've decided to use all as
ahead I won't comment on such people I
mean there's a point at which okay this
is in fact I noticed that ether on our
live stream is is suggesting a function
called freeze that freezes everything
good luck to you that is a very hard
problem
unfortunately the function that freezes
everything the definition of everything
is very hard to make I mean in
activating everything is one thing but
anyway it's a it's a I think you I think
we should just keep it as a pattern
Steven because that integrates some you
could have as alternatives right oh yeah
that's true I mean instead of using less
you just have to use alternatives that's
the only thing the pattern imposes on a
person well I know that but it's look
there's no harm in having it be a list
in fact because the list it's a symbol
right it's a although I admit that we
could okay there's more consistent to
just do that but we could as a courtesy
accept a list there since the list can't
mean anything else since it's a pattern
purely for symbols okay so the issue is
the exclusions here the exclusions I
think are a list or an association I
think we could I think we could do is it
could be a list of symbols or it could
be an association of two fields each of
which is a list of symbols that's fine
and if it's a flat list I think the
correct interpreted the false
interpretation of those is the symbol
type of exclusions rather than the
expression type exclusions okay
let me make a suggestion that one
possibility people might want and we
need a syntax for this this take all the
current exclusions and add to it
right so I'm saying they've already got
the default exclusions automatic I don't
really like this way of doing it but
we've got that and then you want to do
some additional exclusions right I mean
it could just be a binary a boolean
right it could be override default or
you know include default goes to
true/false and you know I would think
that the fault would be not to would be
to overwrite the automatic things rather
than opting in I'm not sure about that I
think people might want to say in
addition to lifting filter data a very
random thing to be put in the
inactivation list they might want some
other you know a bunch of other things
in the inactivation list and the non
inactivation list so to speak
you know I really don't like the fact
that we can't have it all as the second
argument here
I mean I think we could special case it
I mean I first and you know just map it
to blank I mean it feels slightly
limiting although I suppose we could
always right you could do alternatives
of all if you really really wanted to
exclude the head all right I mean
they're ugly workarounds throw that edge
case if you really want it so I'm you
know I think we should support it okay
um I personally wouldn't do it but I
can't claim to have a deep of a deep
objection to it okay all right so let's
let's plan on that and then the question
is how do we represent additions to the
exclusions versus overwriting the
exclusions one comment we have I in a
bunch of other places yeah dick largest
taken largest yes we use it there to
eliminate missing stands things huh boy
something post twelve one is the
calculus of missing okay takes patterns
I take it which is not I mean they I'm
not sure what would be involved in
allowing patterns in the exclusions well
I mean expression is differential route
of blank blank blank right this is right
versus is it lists or blankness I'm not
sure what I'm not sure I though I'm not
in a sense the right but in both cases
we're looking at the head so it's a
slightly different yes I understand
by the way you've got an awful lot of
seashore noise somebody thinking that's
a tie
yeah it's probably new alright
they um okay back to this about to run
out of time um okay look clearly a third
argument is the way to go with this I'm
not completely sure how to do that can
you guys have a think about how to do
the case of adding to the existing third
argument yep
versus I don't quite see that you know I
mean I mean I think between okay all
right
let's just look at these these other
things here for one second just to make
sure that we
I I don't see the need for this what is
the what why discuss proposes into that
it sort of least we can use anything why
do we want that
so I encountered this when working with
commercials at the I didn't want they
were late so I wanted to extract it but
there was no way to well I think I mean
I think his issue is that he's creating
objects which are wrapping naked rules
as opposed to wrapping no his issue is
that he's creating objects they just
want to evaluate and he is doing this is
part of the story of you know unavailing
manipulation which I consider to be an
unfinished story this is a typical
example of that because it's like when
do you evaluate that one I think clearly
you can get
I mean if you don't want the one of
you can use a Coulomb greater than one
but you need to extract it and then it
gets complicated
what why does it get complicated you've
got a list a colon greater than 1 B
colon greater than well you know a colon
greater than 1 plus 1 B colon greater
than 2 plus 2 okay so upon extraction of
a the thing is being returned and then
the 1 plus 1 is evaluated each other
what I want to keep it okay so you want
something that is like what extract has
which is the third argument which is a
hold hmm that's a different thing
right and I mean you can write you can
sort of get what Constantine wants now
right right you just need to use replace
right you replace head of rules with you
know lookup of unev a late it of list of
the rules there's a different there's a
difference okay so the issue is what
would unfortunately now be a fourth
argument after the default which is a
wrapping function yeah oh yes yes yes
because that's the analog of extract
which is the wrapping function as its
third argument correct yep I mean that
would solve your problem right of
wrapping and it seems useful to be able
to have a wrapping thing mm-hmm yeah I
have no problem with adding a wrapping
argument to look up that may even have
been suggested in the past I'm not I
still don't exactly see how he's gotten
from that need to distance I don't
that's not worry about it we don't know
we don't agree with this suggestion but
we do agree with wrapping func you know
wrapping arguments so I suggest be put
in the wrapping argument and be happy
okay
you know we have a live stream is
commenting that he is written the freeze
function and he's asking about the
package repository by which repo means
packet repository it will not be ready
for the 12 1 release unfortunately it's
still being worked on and I would
strongly recommend that type of function
is an ideal type of function for the
function repository I greatly encouraged
to send it in there I think that the the
packet repository just to be clear to
everybody the packet repository is for
people building whole worlds to deploy
in the system that have pallets and
redefine you know whole contexts worth
of symbols and other things that are
very global now you can perfectly well
if all you want to do is introduce the
function fee freeze do it in the
function repository by the way the
function repository can call on things
that are impact let's fact we have some
examples of that going in right now and
in fact it will also be able to call an
external code and all kinds of elaborate
things um but it's still the question is
what is the exposure is it an individual
function sticking its neck out sticking
its head out of the water so to speak or
is it is it
a whole giant Armada of ships so to
speak of you know complete with all
kinds of all kinds of tooling and so on
I think maybe you're over emphasizing
giants ok it could be small but I mean I
agree it's a collection of things right
I mean look at the case that is going in
right now in the function repository is
something that relies on a pack let the
users library link ok so you know that's
a different it's something which just
has more tentacles I also will have
versioning it'll be user contribute
purely user no curation so it'll be you
know simply the user Pacolet repository
and you know anything goes
because the I mean there are certain
packets in the layout that are probably
smaller than the vast majority of
functions and the function repository
because they're really just you know
connecting to things or whatever but
right well fair enough
oh boy I have no idea about this one all
the tasks should not query cloud objects
it should be a separate function right
so I you know I think this is something
that I we haven't really thought through
so I'm not sure we haven't had any prior
discussion okay well I have a discussion
about it it doesn't seem it seems yes it
seems like unless there was some kind of
cache thing that had cloud tasks
available which there could be perhaps I
agree with you that this could be a mess
probably was not a correct design you
talked up after they desired so kind of
without what do you mean so that the
tasks was intended to just give the list
of local of the session tasks what you
have in the computer and then I I
noticed that the object well tasks from
from the cloud hooked up and the comment
afterwards okay so I mean the question
is really just tasks open clothes
without an awl or something give
everything or does it only give local
tasks what we need the way to separate
them yes probably right looks like
persistent location we need it like in
all a local cloud yeah but it might be a
persistence locations I mean there are
task execution locations and so on right
the main question is what should the
default be well clearly not to go off
and query the cloud if that's really
slow yeah
okay you're saying it should take much
less than our second to query the flower
the I agree tasks of cloud is a
perfectly reasonable approach and quite
possibly what we should use okay at
equals but what happened to Sanders
other suggestion about the very nice
syntax for iteration / / Association is
that coming in and I'll be meeting soon
it's sunny it's not like a list of
future topics okay it's fine we should
get to it it's a really nice suggestion
will be quite easy to implement um okay
so alright so I don't think anybody's
opposed to this suggestion if there is
someone that they should speak up I
think as I say in the agenda there I
think the biggest issue is what to call
this thing well is it really desirable
is this really desirable would it ever
be used really really so I think there
are I mean maybe John they still have
John John yeah that's a big fan of this
I didn't propose it but it seemed
perfectly reasonable would I use it
difficult to say without you know having
it available but I could see myself
using it more than I've you know used
some of the other operators we've added
recently in particular Oh all the
composition ones ant star and slash pose
let me tell you something about those my
opinion is that you ascend to different
levels of functional programming okay
because I've seen some people who use
those all the time
I see and I am just entering that zone
of functional programming where I'm
starting to use those a bunch um
mean that you are where you know you
completely grok what a monad is but
you're completely unable to tell the
rest of us what it is that could be
what's happening um no but seriously I
think people go through with respect to
things like that you know an awful lot
of people you know it's it's a big
struggle to learn what a pure function
is once you've learnt that you get those
then you get to you know all kinds of
things like you know fold pair lists and
things like this which you know people
okay
nest list is one level fold list is yet
another level then there are more levels
after that and the the at star slash
star you know I won't claim tonight and
I think and I think you know for the
people who use those operators this at
equal would be a natural operator to add
right because it means you right be you
know operator a slash star operator B
etc etc or whatever composition you want
on the right hand side and then you
don't need to repent on the precedents
we have to recognize carefully yes okay
we can you guys look at that precedence
thing assuming it's at equals what the
precedence would be I kind of like in
terms of similars my kind of like at
equals I think it has very it's much
easier for me to remember what this
would do then at Star versus slash star
um by the way that there's a there's a
people saying that the tasks of cloud
and dresses tasks of local and things
but that's a somewhat urgent issue for
actual it's not hard to do it for one
well so what do you want to do you want
to say tasks of local and things like
that well why don't you guys look at
that I think that's the right way to do
it um okay but so in terms of precedence
I mean the natural thing to compare it
to is plus equal minus equals star equal
slash equal yeah who's used star equal
and the last I haven't used star equal
in at least a decade I've certainly used
plus equal I don't know about star equal
but I certainly use plus equal and I've
been I may not have used star equal in
our language but I'm sure I've used it
in C++ yeah
and if by by the way you talk about
functional programming people but
they're not using assignment well that's
not completely fair but but go ahead
what are you gonna say I was just gonna
say if by use you mean reviewed code
that had in it and yes I've used star
equal in the last couple of years but
it's yeah I mean certainly right it the
the precedence should be relatively low
right closer to equal than to yes that
star and slash star maybe we can just I
don't remember if there's a curious
division and the precedence between plus
equal and equal there's stuff in between
there that you might not have expected I
don't know what the history of what it
is so between those two there's their
form because vertical separator slash
slash
: and nice clash is important
/ / is really important but the question
ampersand o / / is the question if you
say x equals y / / n what does the / /
apply to okay does it do the assignment
before it does the numerical ization
often right and the curious thing is
that is that / / binds tighter than
equal but looser than plus equal right
which is perhaps a realization that you
know no mistake to have it below below
equal or above equal I'm not sure no
it's not obviously wrong to have / /
above equal okay listen
it needs to be looked at I mean I
remember the / / precedence was pretty
carefully thought about yeah and and I'm
not disputing these precedences but
these precedences were decided long
before I was part of the language design
and I don't know what the what the
providence of them is well they were in
version one I mean that's not right but
but but so why why is / / tighter than
set but looser than ad - that's not a
question
okay so you're saying that if I do this
/ / n you're saying that in that case
that the N is to the whole expression oh
yeah well I mean triple-click the / /
and you'll see it okay but do the same
thing with equal and triple click the /
/ n brilliant okay the way it should be
well it's not obvious to me what maybe
it's obvious to you why is that I'll
tell you why I'll tell you why
because this is same a equals the
numerical oz form of B okay
whereas here
you're much more likely to want to say
because this has a return value because
you're using the return value here I
what am I trying to say I not not for
that not for right now I think that was
an omission that it was more complex
than you thought it was I don't think
these were wrong I wish we kept notes I
wonder whether I still have I mean I
mean you might be right but I obviously
I don't and okay all right but well all
right to be continued another time yeah
totally this is not for 12-1 anyway
complaining that a plus equals B slashes
and makes more sense I don't think
that's necessarily correct and I I'm
gonna be forced to find my notes from 33
years ago about why these preferences
were done the way they were which I'm
sure exists unfortunately probably
handwritten so there I mean they'll be
scanned but they're not easy to OCR okay
all right thanks guys on to the next
thing
thank you to focus on the live stream
talk to you soon